the governor of florida has signed a
bill banning teachers from talking to
small children ages kindergarten through
third grade about their own genitals or
encouraging them to change their gender
the overwhelming majority overwhelming
majority of americans including of
democrats agree with that because it's
common sense and the alternative is
disgusting and probably illegal but at
the walt disney corporation
they were infuriated by this disney
called an all hands meeting to discuss
new ways to indoctrinate children
without their parents knowledge chris
ruffo obtained footage from that meeting
here's the executive producer of disney
television animation bragging about
quote injecting queerness into as many
shows as she can
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda i don't have to be
afraid to like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like if you see anything
queer in the show i'm proud of them but
like i just was like no one would stop
me and no one was trying to stop me
okay so here's disney's diversity and
inclusion manager explain to the company
will no longer use the words boys and
girls watch
last summer we we removed all of the um
gendered greetings in relationship to
our life skills so we no longer say
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls we
we've trained we've provided training
for all of our our cast members in
relationship to that so now they know
it's hello everyone or hello friends
degendering your children without
telling you
chris ruffo is a journalist and a
filmmaker and quite a reporter he got
this footage as he's done many times in
the past on related topics we're happy
to have him join us tonight chris thanks
a lot for coming on so what what exactly
was that
so this was an all hands meeting in
response to governor desantis
legislation where
disney had assembled their lgbtqia
activists that they've set up within the
company and they said that they're
deliberately trying to take programming
that goes from even ages two to seven
years old and inject queerness into that
programming they're trying to really
make all of their programs this
left-wing gender ideology compatible and
they're even doing something i think
that is at the height of hypocrisy at
the same time they're falsely accusing
governor desantis of implementing a
don't say gay policy which is not true
at all they were systematically and
simultaneously telling all of their park
employees to eliminate the words ladies
gentlemen boys and girls they're
projecting onto the governor what they
themselves are doing we've caught them
on tape and the evidence is damning
so they have a sexual agenda for
six-year-old children so right there you
think well you know you think that's
illegal in some way it's certainly
immoral it's creepy as hell
and yet you know they're the country's
leading purveyor of children's
programming
that's a problem no
that's right and i think what we can
really see inside the company is that
executives made the decision a few years
ago to create these activist
organizations within the company first
on the issues of race and now on the
issues of gender and sexual orientation
and these activist organizations
essentially have taken moral power from
within the company and the executives
who are really cowardly and craving
individuals just cave anytime that they
want something and so all of these
videos document that whatever these
activists say they're now creating a
tracking program for all disney
children's content to find out exactly
how many uh transgender asexual and
bisexual characters that they're
peppering into the show either in the
foreground or the background
it sounds like a really kind of bizarre
and creepy gender studies experiment on
a college campus but it's being
mainlined into children's programming
all over the world well it sounds like
the behavior of a sex offender i mean
normal people don't sexualize underage
children period they have nothing to do
with sex they're little kids they're
prepubescent but disney doesn't feel
that way it seems like a threat and i
appreciate your exposing it chris ruffo
thank you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight